we got a excellent show as I said
tonight a lot of fun Andy what are you
doing well I'm just doing my job okay
but why you standing like that do I not
normally stand like this no Andy usually
you stand behind the lectern you know
oh right you know what that does make
sense oh yeah III okay
there we go action that's the wrong
camera Andy and you don't have to call
action you never do that what's wrong
with you I'm sorry it's just that we
just come back from our summer break and
I guess I'm a little rusty well now you
know where to stand you know which
camera to look at so let's just get on
with the show
okay cuz it's gonna be a great one isn't
that right Andy I mean I wish I could
say yes but it's probably just gonna be
okay no Andy you're it's supposed to
just say yes no matter what that's what
you do
that's your job can we get HR in here
hello Conan Andy how can i empower you
today hey Jonah I forgot how to do my
job
oh that is no problem Andy I specialize
in employee development and develop
woman so let's get started you need to
make the host believe the irrational
fantasy that he is the funniest person
in the world
okay how do we do this l FTL laughs
first think later okay all right that
makes sense yes
also APL SL a are L paid laughs sounds
like a real laugh yes yeah
and just remember hki VIII a cm he won't
know if it's vodka if it's in a coffee
mug I'm sorry that's completely the
wrong side that is from our CEO training
yeah what I want you to remember is TS y
si AG st sy g CH the sooner you say it's
a great show the sooner you can go home
oh I love going home
so if you forget anything here's a
binder of your official sidekick duties
okay it's empty that's right because
everything you need to know is right in
here now stop looking at my breasts
that's an actionable offense pointing
very good thank you sorry
I feel the pressure you know what Andy
if you ask me HR stands for how rude
good one boy ah there we go
[Music]
[Applause]
you